these are sex issues
today we're trying on stilettos I have
never worn any type of heels before ever
definitely never tried stilettos pop in
my heels virginity today I think they
will makes me feel tall and powerful I
don't know if that's a good thing I mean
I already feel like I intimidate guys
because I'm 510 and I'm issuing a
challenge to myself right now to be able
to run in them I think the littles are
so pretty I'm terrified I've heard girls
say they're comfortable I'm gonna love
them how what is this are you six inches
it sounds standard but it looks
terrifying tell my family I love them oh
my lord
yep I like this this is really five my
instinct is to lean forward and that is
obviously a huge mistake all right
I can't gesture as much or else I'm
gonna fall over
what I would not pass like any field
sobriety test in these are guys
attracted to like the wobbliness I feel
incredibly confident and insecure at the
same time I'm sorry having a little bit
of fun right now
I'm gonna try and run not bad but I feel
like it probably looked really awkward I
wish I had shorts on right now my cows
probably look real good I feel really
like I'm sort of like a super villain in
a movie like stolen the president's
daughter
I feel like I could kick some ass if I
forgot my mace I'd be like whatever cuz
of a guy attacks me it's just like [ __ ]
now you're dead my posture I feel like
is fantastic right now it's good for a
woman who want posture and do not move
need me to do anything though you trying
to see if my butt looks astronomically
amazing but I've seen girls like strut
down the street on these I don't how
they do that I think I could dance in
these I'm nailing it I'm doing it can
you believe this yeah I'm good it's
definitely not as bad as I thought I
think I'd like them but I do like that I
can see like first time I wore skinny
jeans that wasn't comfortable but now
we're them all the time effortless I
kind of have them in love with them I'm
totally rethinking my plan to never buy
apparently that was like surprisingly
way more fun than I anticipated it being
they're not as difficult as I expected
but they are just as uncomfortable as I
expected I feel like my feet are already
swollen after a whole day this would be
miserable
your butt's feeling perky as hell
because it's doing everything it can to
have you not fall over so if anyone were
to grope me at a bar it would be like
rock are they be like intimidated I just
want to show up on the first day
awaiting these you are saying yeah I
might wear heels again someday
can I keep these what guys ever put
themselves through this hell no no way
guys would never walk around with their
toes hurting for 12 hours just to look
hot I feel like Dorothy from Wizard of
Oz who gives no